let's take another call 617 830 4750 is
the number our next caller from the 757
area code caller what's your name and
where you calling from my name is paul
i'm calling from virginia beach awesome
paul what's on your mind um so I voted
for Bernie in the primary yep um and I
loved back in the day I love the idea of
a tuition-free college system but uh the
more I thought about it the more I'm
just thinking like should we put more
emphasis on the K through 12 education
making the high school diploma worth
what it was I don't know in like the
nineteen sixties seventies um especially
now that we're heading towards the more
autonomous era word you're gonna see a
lot of jobs you know just not be able to
be filled yum i was i was wondering your
thoughts on that well you're thinking
about this in the right way which is
it's not just about the cost of college
it's also about what are your earnings
expectations based on what field you go
into in college what is the value of
and/or necessity of different levels of
education you're tying in automation
which is something that neither Hillary
Clinton or Donald Trump really wanted to
talk about during the campaign so you're
thinking about this in sort of a multi
multi faceted way which is absolutely
right I believe that at this point even
if the United States unilaterally said
we are going to focus on improving K
through 12 education particularly with
automation it's not going to be as
necessary to it's not gonna be as good
of an investment even to go in and get a
four-year college degree because so many
jobs are going to be replaced by
machines anyway let's improve k through
12 so that then people can just be ready
to go right into the workforce when they
graduate it's a nice idea if the US
unilaterally did that and poured more
money into K through 12 education didn't
worry about subsidizing or or covering
tuition at state schools as as Bernie
Sanders talked about other countries are
not going to change their approach
in terms of Education and bachelor's
degrees master's degrees phd's etcetera
and what it would ultimately lead to
would be a situation where we have way
fewer jobs because of automation and
increasingly people that on paper are
not even going to be considered for the
jobs by employers because there will be
so many applicants from other countries
that have a more more education and
higher degrees now the way to prevent
that would be you know right now if an
American company wants to hire someone
from outside the US and give them legal
work status they have to say we've done
an open and full search to fill this
position and we've determined that this
candidate from another country is the
best qualified person above and beyond
people in the United States if you have
in the u.s. fewer and fewer college
degrees and more and more foreign
applicants with college degrees it's
going to make it so that that case that
American companies have to make hey we
did try to hire people in the US there's
fewer and fewer people with college
degrees I believe it will actually hurt
the american workforce to the extent
that there will be jobs remaining that
are not automated away that's my sense
of what what you're suggesting right
cool I was also thinking like uh
restructuring the core curriculum
especially in college um just because
for so many uh yeah I feel like general
education just gets in the way of like
what people really want to do even
though I mean there's certain things
like US history and government which I
and totally on board for for both high
school and education obviously to you
know make smarter voters uh I'm seen
with this past election uh and why not
adequate there's internet integrated
curriculum by the way critical thinking
which I graduated yeah I think I think
that's a that's a different conversation
I think we could probably pick classes
that are part of core curriculum which
we could maybe argue are these really
the best classes but bigger picture I
don't think that that's the the lowest
hanging fruit here thank you so much for
the call I really really appreciate it
very very interesting and you're
thinking about this in absolutely the
right way that is going to do it as far
as calls go this week we are out of
time but we will take calls again very
very soon and I look forward to hearing
for more of our viewers the number R is
and will continue to be 617 830 4750 and
you can also go to david pakman.com
slash donate to check out the indy gogo
fundraiser that we are in the middle of
i hope you will contribute